bonsoir ce soir je vais vous parler de
deux notions que d'aucuns jugeraient
totalement comment dire antinomiques et
qui pourtant que pourtant moi je
considère comme étant absolument
indissociables alors de quoi est ce que
je vais vous parler eh bien je vais vous
parler d'entreprise et d'amour alors
rassurez vous je vais pas vous faire un
que sais je sur les meilleures façons de
d'entretenir une relation extra
conjugale sur son lieu de travail
c'est pas du tout l'objet donc ce que je
voudrais partager avec vous c'est en
quoi selon moi l'amour doit être une des
composantes de base de l'entreprise et
ce dès sa création
alors quand je parle d'amour je pense à
cette notion qui englobe la tension là
la confiance la considération l'écoutent
le respect le fun
l'émotion bien évidemment et puis la
séduction et la sincérité ce que je
m'apprête à partager avec vous autant
être clair ce ne sont pas des vérités
universelles
c'est davantage ma conception ma
conviction profonde il issu de mon
parcours d'entrepreneurs et de mon
quotidien de chef d'entreprise
d'ailleurs je pense que assez peu de
chefs d'entreprise dans la partage mais
en revanche je mettrais ma main à couper
que dans les cinq à dix ans qui viennent
on sera capable de faire la différence
entre les entreprises qui se seront
adaptés à ce que je vais vous expliquer
et les autres donc pour moi entreprises
et amour sont totalement indissociables
et pour l'illustrer
je vais m'appuyer sur trois types de
profils
qui interagissent avec le chef
d'entreprise ou l'entrepreneur à savoir
ses proches ses collaborateurs et ses
clients
je vais commencer par les proches
entreprendre c'est prendre des risques
pour moi même
entreprendre c'est innover innover c'est
s'exposer s'exposer dans un univers un
environnement souvent hostile et qu'il
nous attend pas et on prend des coups
partout tout le temps aussi pour avoir
là pour trouver la force de me battre et
d'avancer j'ai eu besoin d'une base
arrière besoin d'un havre de de douceur
vers lequel je pouvais me retourner pour
puiser l'affection la chaleur et l'amour
qui m'ont permis de d'affronter
l'adversité
je vais vous raconter la naissance de ma
boîte en 97 j'étais étudiant quelques
pas d'ici à tour et je me suis je me
suis dit que lâchement j'allais
abandonner mes études pour créer
alloresto le premier site français de
restauration livrée à domicile et au
bout de quelques semaines à travers
après plusieurs mois même passé à
travailler sur mon projet je suis allé à
paris pour signer quelques contrats avec
des avec des restaurants partenaires
malheureusement au bout de plusieurs
semaines parisienne j'avais toujours
signé aucun contrat pire je n'avais eu
aucun rendez vous alors je me suis
accroché je me suis je continue à
investir dans ce projet et puis enfin un
jour ça a souri
un premier rendez vous plus exactement
une restauratrice que j'ai eu au
téléphone m'a dit oh oui venez voir mon
fils demain je suis sûr que ça va
l'intéresser
et le lendemain donc j'arrive dans le
restaurant alors convenu seul truc c'est
que la dame avait dû oublier d'en parler
à son fils et lorsque je suis arrivé
j'étais pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout attendu et je suis rentré il m'a
demandé qu'est ce que vous faites là je
l'écoutais je vais lancer le premier
site français de restauration livrée
internet ça m'intéresse pas mais c'était
mon premier rendez-vous alors j'ai
insisté
femi le comprenais pas le français
internet j'en ai rien à alors de
voir et là je me suis retrouvé sur le
trottoir complètement anéantie et je me
suis dit mais est-ce que j'ai pas commis
la plus grosse connerie de mon existence
à elle abandonné mes études pour lancer
un service qui visiblement était
beaucoup trop en avance sur son temps et
donc j'ai marché
longtemps très longtemps jusqu'à chez
moi ou plus exactement chez ma tante qui
m'héberger à l'époque
et là quand je suis arrivée dans
l'appartement elle a vu tout de suite
que ça allait pas et donc je lui ai dit
écoute je crois que j'ai tout arrêté
je lui ai raconté ce qui s'était passé
et puis elle a écouté et puis elle m'a
dit tu sais sébastien on n'a pas eu
l'occasion d'en parler mais moi je
trouve que c'est super ce que tu fais
vraiment on y voit tu met du coeur que
tu y investit de l'énergie franchement
forcément tu as pris un risque tu dois
t'attendre à ce genre de désillusion
donc c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
demain dommage de tout arrêter
maintenant
mais si toi une chance tu le mérites et
là je me suis dit waouh à dire donc je
retourne à mon bureau
et puis j'ai repassé quelques appels
malheureusement les premiers ont été
encore infructueuses
et puis ça s'est enchaîné ça s'est
enchaîné toujours à l'échec
jusqu'au moment où un nouveau
restaurateur venu expliquer que ben non
il travaillerait pas avec moi ça
n'intéressait pas et là j'ai senti un
truc n'est pas encore accroché il senti
un truc monté une espèce de chaleur un
truc et je lui ai dit non mais est-ce
que vous pouvez m'expliquer ce qui se
passe expliqué moi à moi je vous appelle
vous faites de la restauration livrée
moi je veux dit je lance le premier site
de restauration livrée à domicile ça
devrait vous intéresser quand même hein
y'a pas de frais d'inscription n'y a pas
de frais d'abonnement vous allez
uniquement de rémunérés à la commission
sur les commandes que je vous envoie un
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire si vous
serez sauvés aucune commande ça vous
coûte 0 vous prenez aucun risque c'est
moi qui prend tous les risques
alors il est où le problème et là il ya
eu un silence
là dessus il faut que tu insistes bon
alors demain rendez vous à 11 0 à 14
heures et à 14 heures ben j'ai signé mon
premier contrat
donc ce que je voulais vous dire par là
c'est qu'en fait vous avez sans doute
dans votre entourage des entrepreneurs
dès que ce soit des amis ou des membres
de votre famille un père une mère un
fils une fille un époux une épouse enfin
je vais m'arrêter là vous avez compris
le concept
soyez attentifs sachez atral écoute
lorsqu ils en éprouvent le besoin parce
que un entrepreneur ça a besoin d'amour
cet amour cet amour il le transforme en
carburant en une énergie qui va lui
permettre de déplacer des montagnes
l'amour c'est le carburant
d'entrepreneurs la deuxième typologie de
personnes aujourd'hui vous parler ce
sont les collaborateurs
qu'attend un employeur de ses
collaborateurs
globalement je pense que ça n'a pas
changé au cours des 50 dernières années
on peut parler d'engagement on peut
parler d'implication de confiance de
fiabilité on peut parler également de
performances
là encore on est dans un champ lexical
qu'on pourrait raccrocher à la notion
d'amour même s'agissant de la
performance d'ailleurs mais on en
parlera peut-être un peu plus tard en
revanche ce qu'attendent les
collaborateurs de l'employeur ça c'est
en pleine évolution est notamment sous
l'effet des jeunes générations et
principalement de la génération y la
génération y les 20 35 ans le fondement
même de ce changement
c'est le deal ok je veux bien travailler
pour toi mais qu'est ce que tu
m'apportes en quoi est ce que toi tu va
m'aider à me développer à m'améliorer a
progressé à m'épanouir
un des changements les plus marquants
c'est le besoin d'admirer son patron et
cette admiration
bien évidemment elle trouve son origine
dans
ce dans les succès passés
mais elle est encore amplifié cette à
demain admiration par le fait que ce
professionnel reconnu c'est écouter
conseiller guider un management de
proximité et un leadership bienveillant
il ya une grande étude qui a été
réalisée par je ne sais pas par qui mais
qui s'appelle la grande invasion et qui
a interrogé trois mille jeunes de 15 à
20 ans et on leur a demandé qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un bon patron et dans 68%
des cas un bon patron c'est un patron
qui est qui fait confiance à ses équipes
à 62 % des cas c'est un patron qui
écoute et tout en bas à 22%
on a l'autorité est encore plus bas à
11%
on a la confiance en soi donc plus qu'un
manager ces nouvelles générations
elle recherche un coach qui accompagnent
au quotidien qui vaut un coach qui va
valoriser qui va reconnaître les
compétences de cette jeune génération
cette jeune génération
elle a besoin elle l a complètement
détruit
les séparations entre la vie pro et la
bri et la vie perso elle s'inscrit
totalement en désaccord avec les
générations précédentes elle elle ne
joue plus un rôle elle est totalement à
la recherche de kif et de bonne ambiance
comme dans sa vie perso et est la
recherche également du sens et elle
s'attend à ce que le chef d'entreprise
lui en apporte une partie dans ma boîte
je demande toutes les trois semaines
un entrepreneur de venir parler de son
parcours de ses réussites de ses échecs
à l'ensemble de mes équipes alors ma
volonté c'est de titiller la fibre
entrepreneuriale de mes collaborateurs
alors il ya plein de gens qui me disent
mais ça va pas tu es fou ils vont se
barrer pour monter leur boîte
moi je pense que je suis pas fou
je pense que je suis pas fou parce que
si parmi mes équipes
il y en a certains qui ont la fibre
entrepreneuriale je pense qu'il serait
ce serait pas éclaté chez moi en tant
que salarié donc je préfère mettre en
oeuvre ce qui est à ma portée pour leur
permettre de s'épanouir
la troisième typologie de personnes dont
je vais vous parler ce sont les clients
je sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué vous
aussi mais moi il ya des chaînes
entreprises ils me font penser à des
mecs en boîte de nuit
on dirait qu'ils sont là pour choper
pour choper des nouveaux clients ils
sont incroyables il drague vous it et
déborde et technique assez assez
complexe parfois pour pour les séduire
ils investissent de l'argent parfois
beaucoup pour les conquérir
et puis une fois qu'ils leurs proies
dans leurs filets et ben voilà
l'histoire est finie et ils repartent
choper de nouveaux clients moi je pense
que justement c'est à ce moment là que
tout commence que tout que l'histoire
entre une entreprise et son client comme
elle commence juste après la première
commande ou le premier h et que doux
tout doit être gérée comme dans une
histoire d'amour comme dans une histoire
d'amour il va falloir séduire comme dans
une histoire d'amour il va falloir
développer la complicité et la
connivence pour ça les réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment génial comme dans une
histoire d'amour il va falloir être
réactif être aller coûte être attentif
comme dans une histoire d'amour il va
falloir surprendre et fun
nous on s'est totalement inscrit dans
cette logique là quand on 2012
on a lancé une campagne de com
totalement décalé qui mettait en scène
qui dès qu'il détournait les clichés des
films pour adultes
ambre mettant en scène une des actrices
fétiches de ce cinéma qui s'appelait
katsuni et aurait laquelle on faisait
dire pas ce soir
mais comme dans une histoire d'amour il
faut il faut éviter la routine
il faut donc amener de la nouveauté et
là ça passe très souvent par
l'innovation
alors rassurez vous il ya quelque chose
sur lequel on a le droit de se tromper
on a le droit de parler de bon on a le
droit de se rater
mais là encore comme dans une histoire
d'amour eh bien il suffit de le
reconnaître et s'est excusé nous
lorsqu'une cliente vit une expérience un
peu délicate
eh bien on lui fait envoyer un beau gros
bouquet de fleurs voilà c'est notre
façon à nous de nous excuser de
reconnaître notre erreur il faudrait
surtout pas prendre ce que je suis en
train de vous dire comme une espèce de
catalogue de techniques à appliquer
parce que il faut pas perdre de vue
qu'un client ne devient un fidèle que
pour les raisons très simples la
considération voulu porter la qualité de
vos produits
le plaisir et le confort qu'ils à s'en
servir l'image qu'il a de lui-même là
lorsqu ils les utilisent celle qu'il
renvoie à son entourage et enfin
l'attention et l'écoutent dont le dont
il jouit lorsqu'il a un problème ou une
une remarque à formuler tout le reste
tout le reste est inutile si ces
fondamentaux là ne sont pas respectés et
2 quoi nous parle ses fondamentaux
si ce n'est de respect de plaisir de
bien-être de confiance et d'émotion
il ya quelques jours j'ai pris le train
et il avait une quarantaine de minutes
de retard
le contrôleur a super bien joué son rôle
j'ai même reçu un sms pour me dire que
mme expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles le train est en retard
super mais une fois en garde
on nous a dit bon bah voilà si vous
voulez récupérer 1
vous devez récupérer une une enveloppe
pour écrire au service client et obtenir
un dédommagement
et c'est là que ça déconne c'est là que
ça déconne ils savent ils me connaissent
j'ai pris mon billet sur internet
ils y jouent ils ont bien vu ils ont été
capables de mort et sms pour me prévenir
du retard et maintenant il faudrait que
je leur écrivent pour kiel pour obtenir
un geste commercial
ils ont toutes les informations pour le
faire donc c'est là qu'on saisit en fait
que dans cette boîte l'amour du client
n'existe pas et qu'on ne fait en fait qu
appliquer des techniques que l'on met
bout à bout et donc on sans quoi on
ressent une chose c'est que on a
principalement pas envie que vous
demandiez un geste commercial
et c'est là que il ya un hic je trouve
dans toute cette démarche qui aurait pu
être vraiment parfaite mais le hic dans
cette démarche c'est qu'ils manquent la
st c'est rites et or nous tous individus
en tant qu'être humain est ce que je
vais vous dire c'est sans doute encore
plus vrai pour les jeunes générations
on recherche de plus en plus cette
sincérité et cette authenticité par pur
respect respect de ce que nous sommes et
respect de la confiance que nous
accordons alors on l'a vu ensemble
la notion d'amour reste quand même assez
complexe à définir
pour autant il n'en demeure pas moins
que je suis convaincu qu'on en retrouve
de très nombreuses facettes dans
l'ensemble des relations qui existent
autour et autour et au saint pardon de
l'entreprise alors je vous invite
vous aussi à dans votre vie
professionnelle a commencé à insuffler
de la moa si cette notion vous paraît
encore un petit peu trop abstraite
commencé peut-être par des preuves
d'amour des preuves d'amour sincère
vous l'avez compris mais des preuves
d'amour l'enjeu est de taille parce que
dans les cinq à dix ans qui viennent
je suis convaincu que les entreprises
qui ont qu'ils auront compris et qu'ils
auront intégré à leur mode de
fonctionnement seront beaucoup plus
performante que les autres parce que la
génération y adhère totalement à ce
courant de pensée et qui en plus elle a
déjà commencé à bouleverser l'ensemble
des codes qui régissent les rapports
qu'elle a à l'entreprise qu'elle soit
qu'elles en soient salariés ou qu'elle
en soit clientes et ne vous méprenez pas
sur une chose ne vous méprenez pas sur
la vitesse de propagation de ces
nouvelles valeurs autour de l'entreprise
car cette jeune génération
elle contrôle le plus grand et le plus
grand un influenceur du monde
les réseaux sociaux alors si je ne vous
ai pas convaincus
et bien ne vous dit pour autant pas que
au pire ça va être qu'un mauvais moment
à passer parce que la génération z qui
succédera à la génération y s'inscrit
totalement dans la démarche de cette
dernière mais de façon plus exacerbée et
plus intenses alors je pense qu'il est
grand temps de remettre de l'amour dans
nos vies qu'elle soit professionnelle ou
perso c'est plutôt cool comme programme
bonne fin de soirée
merci